[Music]
hey joe
you know how you have been saying that
you kind of want to try van life
i'm going to next week but what's up
well i'll tell you what i can tell
the detail please well uh recently there
was a survey done
from this moving company called move.org
and they
found that 52 percent of americans are
considering living full-time or
part-time in rvs or camper vans
50 percent two wow
half of america wants to be a traveling
carnival
no those are surveyed yeah which is like
200 people in some random city did you
take the survey
what did they do [ __ ] survey portland
i don't know
yeah man that's still a lot though i
know so
everything in your life in this on
wheels they went to the van capital of
the world and asked fit
as a hundred people would you be down to
live like this forever well they only
asked three people
that they want to live in campervan
outfitted with amenities like
beds stoves storage units a bathroom and
wi-fi
dude rvs and all these things are like
they're selling and everything is going
do you think all the rapists are like
man they're driving up the van prices
[Laughter]
i think so there's definitely some type
of forum some group chat that's up in
arms
bats are going up in prices all the
white vans are gone
[ __ ] the chinese mafia what the hell man
how are we gonna do the [ __ ] slide
open the door
uh yeah i don't know i don't know if i
would ever do it i'm not very like
outdoorsy you know but you're indoors
in in cars
like i i kind of associate it with
camping
kind of yes yeah but very much
it's glamping yeah because all the
amenities no it's clampy it's glamour
camping because some people got showers
and stuff
yeah right right but like what are some
things in real life that it's missing
though no but you should see it
space it looks better than some people's
homes
like someone oh my god well if you went
to an if you got an rv though
like some of them the luxury rvs are
amazing
he's getting wet for these [ __ ] rv's
you guys an rv or a van like uh like a
retrofitted van and like with like all
the cool [ __ ] inside
what i really want is an off-road truck
camper
damn those are like armored vehicles
they're massive you could be out like in
the forest for days
like cool you know but those are like
half a million dollars like the purple
like the prepper people oh remember in
the goofy movie
remembering goofy movie there was that
big army with all the extra yeah
and then they were like i love that [ __ ]
yeah our
rv is dope because so we went on an rv
trip i think last year or two years ago
and then once you park you can literally
press this button
and then the master bedroom like extends
four feet on each side and you have a
living room of all that stuff
but the theme with an rv like when we're
trying to explore yosemite
like there's these twisty windy roads
and then i'm like oh i see why
where a van is way more mobile you know
you can go it's like the rv is super
long and it
it's like pretty much just for
straightaways and if you want to go like
into
and then like adventure it's kind of
hard and you can't go through
drive-throughs
yeah the rv right yeah go inside we
should go to sonics and then you got
people like
coming up
or you did you attach a card to your rv
because most people do that too
there's those ones too they'll just have
their car as like the other option
it's luxury living dude because i'm okay
with just the hammock
i actually think i like hammocks the
most i think
camping and tents are it's more rough
yeah actually i have not camped a day in
my life
me neither i'm so low maintenance as as
a female
but i'm kind of like bougie in the sense
of like i love a hotel
you know what i mean i love it i'm nice
even with like coachella and stuff like
that it's like i like the idea of like
camping i've been to coachella
um but you got a hotel yeah but i did
like hotel style mm-hmm
would you cash surf not a couple times i
did yeah
it's the same thing as camping but
you're inside
you're inside a tent or yeah but like in
a little tent there's like bugs that
could come in i don't know mosquitoes
they [ __ ] me up camping is a lot of
for sure you know isn't this nice guys
yeah if i could just get rid of the bug
thing i think i would just absolutely
love camping but the bug thing screws it
up for me
i got um this group shout out to cuckoo
campers
they ran out these vans right of
different sizes and stuff
and then it's like basically um like the
one i'm getting
it could sleep like four or five people
do you have to go somewhere else to get
these vans
uh they have uh one in iceland like a
company in iceland and they have one
here
in colorado so you have to go to
colorado yeah i'm going to colorado and
then um
it's pretty dope though because every
it's everything is just there
so like you don't need to set up a tent
nothing you just drive
you park you sleep in there you get up
and then you explore hike do whatever
you want that's cool
yeah you could cook in there whatever
that's something that we've
been wanting to do like really badly is
to go do an rv trip
and then see what that's like because we
were we were planning on doing a trip to
go to dallas to go visit his family
she's doing an rv because i don't want
to do i'm like scared of planes right
now so all right
i don't want to fly anywhere i saw an
article about how like you really can't
catch it on a plane
yeah that's what they say why not see
that it's actually really safe on plane
yeah filtration and [ __ ] yeah it's
really good yeah
me and chia debated doing an rv trip
from here to [ __ ] regina saskatchewan
because like you know now would be the
time to travel it's like her second
trimester
oh baby moon little baby moon no no no
we don't want a baby when it's your
family
oh we just want to see her family we
went to your family before it's too late
for her to travel
you know what i'm saying because they
haven't seen her as a pregnant person
right
but then like she doesn't really want to
fly and so we're like well [ __ ]
well let's just rent an rv and drive
through like you know explore america a
little bit we're thinking
see a little bear too wow wait what
toronto regina saskatchewan oh
regina is right above montana is that
how you pronounce that regina i've never
told you guys
the story of regina pronunciation no
it's not like
it says yes um yeah i'm a bad friend
it spelled like i mean we tell so many
stories on this [ __ ] no and plus he
probably wasn't here that's why
okay well it's pronounced it's spelled
like regina but it's pronounced vagina
and i remember the first time i'll just
tell the story again the first time i
was
going to visit her i had just done my
first like one of my first shows in
canada i was in calgary
and i was um the promoter was like oh
wait where are you going after this i
was like i'm gonna go visit this girl
i'm talking to in regina
she was like oh you going to regina and
i was like nice good one
oh cause you're going to go get some
really yeah she's making a joke and then
i was at the airport and then i heard
like oh last call for regina i was like
and then and then so you get out there
yeah and
since they live there they you know
they're unfazed by yeah funny vagina
yeah and since i've been doing it for
i've been going for like a few years i
didn't think it was funny anymore
until one day her brother was car
shopping
and he was trying to find a used car and
someone was like just go to use
regina.com
so i started cracking up and they're
like what a vagina
yeah that's party
so they're always like keep your regina
clean or they'll say like regina the
city that rhymes with fun
so that's what she's from is that near
toronto no why did i always think
why are you forcing this toronto thing
yeah
all she knows is toronto or vancouver
that was me too
she lived next to drake i know look at
your phone so yeah i do love drake so
much she's a drake lover
and plus i i let people think that she
was from toronto for the longest time
because i didn't want her to know i
didn't want the fans to know where she
actually lived
regina so whenever they was like oh yeah
you go from front i'm like yeah yeah
that i see you should go on a rv trip we
went from uh here
to palm through palm springs to lake
havasu and then to grand canyon and then
back through vegas and then fun fact the
only place you can park
a rv in vegas is circus circus they
actually have a
movie plug-ins it's the only main casino
that has it
and they have a great steak that's why
there's so much trailer trash
at circus and then we came back and it
was fun
it was super fun how many days was that
um i think maybe like
just under seven days oh you did all of
that in just a week yeah it just took
our time
oh that sounds really fun it does that's
not gonna do that with joe
we're going this week who's we uh
me and my friends oh he was like i
wasn't ready to answer
but we want names so for the rv thingy
you me i mean you're saying plug
plug-ups or plug-ins whatever like what
is it that you plug
plugs the way rv works is yes you have
running water and you have a toilet and
shower and stuff right
um but that only lasts you for a few
days so every
every couple of days you're gonna have
to plug in and to like take out the
waste
so um so when you go to like it's easy
it's easy it's easy so like you go you
go
when you go to an rv site like in like
let's say you you pull off the side of
the road and you guys [ __ ] and shower
and cook that's perfectly fine
um but if you go into an rv site and you
plug the power and the water and the
waste it's pretty much a house
oh it turns into a house and it's like a
fully running thing wow so that's what's
really cool about it do you teach you
and stuff like how to do this yeah how
do you know
he explained it and then so while she
was explaining it i'm like i'm just
going to record her on my video
because i feel like i'm gonna forget
yeah so i do have a video somewhere
of someone explaining it to me but did
you need to watch the video again to
remember what how to do it
no because then the minute we started
the trip we're just like let's not
use any of this stuff just let's not
prove if we can help it yeah
should we try to poo in real bathrooms
yeah you don't want to save it up in
there yeah i don't like that most um
tour bus door tour buses like when
artists are on tour and [ __ ] the rules
always like don't number two on the
beach because this is an emergency
right well yeah because back then i used
to go on these tours like these asian
tourists like hurst castle and like
yosemite with my mom you know
you know those and it would be like a
charter bus yeah
with like a bathroom in the back and i'm
like
i'm so grossed out by it like ac in the
rv works [ __ ] good
like at night when you're sleeping works
so good the what is it on at night
yeah yeah yeah how okay without the
engine running
oh so you have it plugged in into it
like when you're at like an actual
rv site you can plug it in and it just
turns straight up into a house
interesting which is really cool would
you ever buy a rv
no no because i don't go enough and it's
like almost the cost of a small house
yeah that's why it's good to rent yeah i
see um how about when you're not plugged
in do you are you able to keep things
running uh you are
but then you're running on i think the
either the other generator or the
battery
so you're just eating the juices up but
you can that's what it's made for
yeah you charge it at the plug-in place
so it's it's it's made for you to go
like let's say from one rv site
and then maybe a couple days without it
but then once you get somewhere else you
got to plug in again
so you have to plan out like where you
can stop yeah i had this app
it was really cool so the apple not only
showed me where all the rv plug-in sites
are
on the trip but also where all the
freeway over past clearances
what cause imagine like oh my goodness
like your rv is like 13 feet tall
and the bridge is at 10. oh my no so you
can't use regular google maps you have
to map
through the app so it tells you what the
places you can go
that's like my worst thing yeah imagine
you're driving like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
in that case what would you do if you're
literally in the middle of the freeway
you realize you won't clear it do you
just stop and like what reverse
like what the [ __ ] do you do
how do you do it you stop you get out of
the car you
push it to the side
of it
i'm down i'm down
[Music]